did you learn any lessons about
directing actors that would be helpful
for other first-time directors yeah
fortunately being an actor first I knew
how I liked being directed so I was able
to translate that to my actors number
one is stories first for anyone actors
or expertise their story is first that's
the most important thing and when when
you are directing actors actors are
smart people we're emotionally smart
right so speak to them in a way that is
prodding ideas or inviting ideas versus
telling them exactly what to do how to
say a line you don't want to give anyone
a line reading because you're the
director here you're not the actor you
want to say you know stuff like okay so
so this is what the character is feeling
at this moment because because of this
moment earlier right what do you think
what do you think he's feeling it in
your in your perspective and then you
start to talk back and forth throw ideas
spit ball and then you kind of come to a
consensus if you see a take for example
in my film we had a moment where our
main act one of our actors he is Michael
King he plays the character Ted he it's
it's the climax of the film is a very
emotional moment my character's crying
and he's trying to console the character
he starts crying and it's a lot of
emotions the crying tears I look at him
I say hey your character wouldn't be
crying right now
alright your character has has completed
his arc he's strong he's he's he's he's
no longer this individual who's gonna be
he'll be vulnerable with him but you're
his rock right and then I gave him that
kind of direction it was more
metaphorical and he said got it and then
he was able to change his delivery right
I didn't tell him how to deliver it I
told him what the emotions behind the
delivery were and he interpreted that so
I think in to make a longer story short
is really think about the emotions speak
to an actor emotionally metaphors get
them to understand your your the
feelings of the character and then let
them interpret and make that physical
right if that makes sense
yeah because you talked about the like a
high emotional IQ yes yeah yeah in an
intellect but all emotional into it as
well
yeah absolutely so being sensitive to
that and also knowing that they're gonna
be able to take it and mm-hmm you don't
have to kind of like spell it yeah yeah
I don't you'll have to spell it out you
know save the line this way because of
this you know just say this is what the
character is going through this is at
this moment and if you have to be a
logical director and say alright we're
at we're at the midpoint of the film
this is the biggest revelation this is
an explosion this is something big
happening all right your characters come
this far in this moment we need to
exemplify those feelings right if I need
you to go bigger I'll say go bigger if I
need you to go smaller go smaller
whatever but trust that your actors can
can speak emotional languages and and
that they will then translate that into
a physical action or being a presence
but but be be concise be clear and just
be be confident you know become know
that know that you're the director and
that they're looking to you for for
advice give them notes give them note
the actors love getting notes and if you
don't have any that's fine too but just
make sure that the notes are our I love
getting it in you know they're
emotionally based feel this because of
this or or what do you think happens
here you know I think it's happened too
because of this and then just let them
translate that what if you have to have
a conversation that it's not a negative
but it's more it's not something that
you want to do in front of the whole
cast yeah oh that's good that's good
so if it's if it's a more sensitive
issue you can simply pull the actor
aside because you're the director
all right let's discuss this we have
this here I need to clarify some things
I need you to clarify something
what's on your mind why aren't you
getting to this beat why aren't you
hitting this this emotional moment
what's what's going on in mind and work
through it you must be a psychologist in
a way you really do because sometimes
you have to you have to help them
understand the discover the characters
because as a director you should know
them as well as them right and the story
so as long as you pull them aside gently
say hey what's going on with what do you
feel in our
than blocking you if so what is it how
can I help you break that do I need to
give you something different can can we
motivate you a different way and and
you'll start talking those things out
and then go into the scene with the
people and work through it I always did
that I never never give a note in public
I always gave I pulled him aside really
quick could be the smallest note in the
world hey try it this way
do this do that and then they would go
back into it because I didn't want to
expose anybody's process you know I want
to be gentle about it so I just pulled
him aside and said hey let's let's work
this so that's how I did it and it works
for me as an actor that way so any
director directs me knows that pull me
aside give me a couple thoughts I'll
throw my thoughts will work
you